here we go
in three
two
one
[Music]
what do we have here yeah here i thought
we were special fellas this here's
bagman hang man whatever what the hell
kind of mission is this
[Music]
everyone here is the best there is
who the hell are they gonna get to teach
us
captain pete maverick mitchell
let me be perfectly blunt
you are not my first choice you were
here at the request of admiral kazansky
aka iceman he seems to think that you
have something left to offer the navy
what that is i can't imagine
you all due respect sir i'm not a
teacher
i just want to manage expectations
good morning aviators
this is your captain speaking
and we're off
here we go
in three
two
one
we're going into combat on a level no
living pilot's ever seen
not even him
you think up there you're dead believe
me
my dad believed in you
i'm not gonna make the same mistake
[Music]
someone's not coming back from this
those are your pilots
anything happens to them
you will never forgive yourself
no turning back now
[Music]
having any fun yet
[Music]
[Music]
you